La mer noie.
La mer absorbe.
La mer prend, la mer fait peur.
Elle incarne un univers froid, sombre, inconnu,
et est donc le vaisseau parfait dans de nombreuses
croyances pour transporter les morts vers
leur nouvelle demeure.
Pour cela elle est indissociable du bateau
ou navire qui apparaît sans prévenir et
emporte avec lui les trépassés.
Qu'ils soit la barque de Charon ou le bag
noz breton, les navires des morts préexistent
à toutes les légendes de vaisseaux fantômes
et les ont probablement inspirés.
Les vaisseaux fantômes...
Des apparitions soudaines de navires vides,
délabrés ou luminescents, qui prennent le
pas au XVIIIe siècle sur les légendes de
sirènes et de léviathans si courantes durant
le Moyen Âge.
Si je vous parle du Hollandais Volant, vous
connaissez sûrement au moins de nom ce navire
légendaire rendu populaire par Wagner ou
Pirates des Caraïbes, selon vos centres d'intérêt.
Il s'agirait d'un vaisseau maudit, ayant pactisé
avec le diable dans la deuxième moitié du
XVIIe siècle et condamné à errer sur les
mers depuis.
Cette légende apparaît dans les années
1790 et se développe dans la littérature
du XIXe siècle, dans une telle diversité
de supports et de témoignages qu'il est impossible
de remonter à l'origine de l'histoire.
C'est le propre des légendes, me direz-vous,
et c'est le cas de la plupart des légendes
tournant autour des vaisseaux fantôme.
Le Caleuche [kaléoutché], par exemple, est
un navire fantôme du folklore chilien, qui
apparaîtrait illuminé au large de l'île
de Chiloé et à bord duquel on entendrait
des sons de fête de ses passagers promis
à une vie éternelle.
Difficile ici de se raccrocher à la réalité,
puisque la légende en question ne fait référence
à aucun naufrage.
Ce n'est pas le cas du Tricoleur ou Tricolour,
puisque la légende qui l'entoure ferait référence
à un vrai navire.
Le 5 janvier 1937, l'équipage du Khosron
aurait aperçu un navire, le Tricolour, qui
aurait disparu après les avoir longés par
bâbord.
En vérifiant les cartes de la région, le
capitaine aurait découvert la mention du
M.S.
Tricolour, coulé à cet endroit précis six
ans plus tôt.
Malheureusement, impossible de retrouver des
preuves du Tricolour et du Khosron, dont les
noms ne figurent que sur des sites friands
de légendes et de paranormal, les mythes
2.0.
On retrouve la même idée avec le Lady Lovibond,
une goélette qui se serait échouée en 1748
sur un banc de sable au large du Kent.
D'après la légende, le navire réapparaîtrait
tous les cinquante ans entouré d'une lueur
verdâtre.
Seul bémol, encore une fois, la première
mention de ce vaisseau fantôme vient d'un
article de journal de 1924 et semble non pas
sortir des eaux mais de l'esprit du journaliste
qui l'a inventé.
Les inventions journalistiques de ce type
sont courantes, et on pourrait aussi citer
celle du Marlborough, trois mâts disparu
en 1890 et retrouvé dans des circonstances
macabres vingt ans plus tard.
A lire dans votre supplément illustré du
Petit Journal du 19 octobre 1913, la suite
va vous surprendre.
Parfois, pourtant, les vaisseau-fantôme tirent
leur origine d'un vrai navire, d'un naufrage
avéré.
C'est le cas du Princess Augusta, qui fit
naufrage au large de New York en 1738.
Rien d'exceptionnel jusque là, si ce n'est
que l'histoire devint une légende, la légende
devint un mythe...
Et je vais arrêter cette citation du Seigneur
des Anneaux ici: le navire aurait été
aperçu à plusieurs reprises depuis, enflammé,
entre Noël et le nouvel an ou précédent
une tempête.
Ces apparitions enflammées ne sont pas rares:
on les retrouve dans la légende de la Baie
des Chaleurs, où un navire se serait échoué
au XVIIIe siècle et hanterait les lieux depuis
en prenant l'apparence d'une boule de feu.
Il est vrai que les catastrophes maritimes
donnent souvent envie d'imaginer ce qui pourrait
se passer ensuite, entre deux eaux.
Le naufrage du SS Valencia en 1906, et ses
136 morts, donne lieu à des apparitions légendaires
au même titre que le Titanic a entraîné
l'invention de nombreuses légendes marines.
Au delà du désir courant de trouver une
explication surnaturelle à tout phénomène
inexpliqué, comment comprendre ces apparitions?
Comment expliquer des hallucinations répandues
dans une telle ampleur parmi les marins et
autres passagers des mers?
On peut imaginer différentes hypothèses:
mirages, gaz inflammables remontant à la
surface, phénomènes de bioluminescences
ou feux de saint-Elme, qui provoquent parfois
des halos entourant les navires.
Mais l'explication est parfois toute simple
et nous permet d'aller à l'abordage des vrais
vaisseaux-fantômes, ceux qui hantent de plus
en plus les mers à partir du XVIIIe siècle,
justement, avec le développement du commerce
international: les épaves dérivantes.
Les épaves dérivantes sont des navires abandonnés,
souvent en haute mer, pour différentes raisons.
Il peut s'agir d'un incendie qui se serait
éteint ensuite, d'un navire prenant l'eau
mais continuant de flotter par la suite, ou
pire encore d'une maladie déclarée à bord
qui aurait tué tout l'équipage et aurait
condamné le navire à errer avec sa cargaison
de cadavres à bord.
Heureusement, ce cas est plutôt rare et le
seul cas où je l'ai retrouvé dans mes recherches
est dans les aventures d'Arthur Gordon Pym
d'Allan Poe.
Un roman, donc.
«Le brick venait à nous lentement et avec
plus de certitude dans sa manoeuvre, et (je
ne puis parler de sang-froid de cette aventure)
nos cœurs sautaient follement dans nos poitrines,
et nous répandions toute notre âme en cris
d’allégresse et en actions de grâces à
Dieu (...). Soudainement, du mystérieux navire,
qui était maintenant tout proche de nous,
nous arrivèrent, portées sur l’océan,
une odeur, une puanteur telles, qu’il n’y
a pas dans le monde de mots pour l’exprimer
: infernales, suffocantes, intolérables,
inconcevables ! J’ouvris la bouche pour
respirer, et, me tournant vers mes camarades,
je m’aperçus qu’ils étaient plus pâles
que du marbre.
(...) Oublierai-je jamais la triple horreur
de ce spectacle ? Vingt-cinq ou trente corps
humains, parmi lesquels quelques femmes, gisaient
disséminés çà et là, entre l’arrière
et la cuisine, dans le dernier et le plus
dégoûtant état de putréfaction ! Nous
vîmes clairement qu’il n’y avait pas
une âme vivante sur ce bateau maudit !»
Pour revenir à la réalité, de nombreux
cas de ces vaisseaux fantôme, comme on les
appelle injustement, existent.
Le Baychimo était un cargo à vapeur construit
en 1914 et affecté au transport des fourrures
le long de la côte Canadienne.
Il est pris dans les glaces en 1931 et contraint
à l'abandon.
Il continue d'être aperçu à plusieurs reprises,
toujours pris dans la banquise à différents
endroits de l'Arctique, et sa dernière apparition
remonte à 1969.
Il a probablement coulé depuis.
Le Ryo Un Maru repose lui aussi au fond des
mers à présent, mais ce chalutier japonais
à la dérive depuis le tsunami de 2011 n'est
retrouvé qu'un an plus tard, à la dérive
au large de la Colombie Britannique.
Il est alors coulé par les gardes côte à
cause du danger qu'il représente.
Le MV Lyubov Orlova était déjà en piteux
état lorsqu'il disparaît en mer en 2013
puisqu'il était en train de se faire remorquer
vers son site de démantèlement, mais lorsque
le câble se rompt il part à la dérive...
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui, puisqu'il se trouve
probablement toujours quelque part dans l'Atlantique.
Dans tous les cas présentés jusqu'ici, on
sait bien où se trouvait l'équipage et la
présence de ces vaisseaux fantômes sur la
mer, toute dangereuse qu'elle est, n'est pas
un mystère.
Dans le cas du Mary Celeste, en revanche,
on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé.
Le 7 novembre 1872, le navire quitte New York
en direction de Gênes.
Un deuxième navire, le Dei Gratia, prend
la même route le 15 novembre.
Le 4 décembre, entre les Açores et le Portugal,
il repère un navire qui approche en zigzaguant
et sans ses voiles: il s'agit du Mary Céleste,
endommagé, en partie inondé, vide et dépourvu
de son embarcation de sauvetage.
La dernière entrée dans le livre de bord
date de neuf jours auparavant et indique qu'il
se trouvait alors à 740 km de là mais rien
n'indique pourquoi l'ensemble de l'équipage
avait fui le navire, emportant seulement des
documents du navire et les instruments de
navigation.
Le Mary Céleste est ramené en Europe, et
connaît un destin pas plus heureux puisqu'il
termine ses jours échoué volontairement
sur un récif en 1885, pour une tentative
d'arnaque à l'assurance.
Quant à l'équipage de 1872, personne n'en
a plus entendu parler.
Il est probable que la chaloupe de secours,
au milieu de l'Atlantique, ait chaviré et
qu'il ait terminé noyé.
Durant les audiences pour déterminer les
causes de l'abandon du navire, il a été
avancé qu'une mutinerie aurait pu avoir lieu
puisque des traces de coups et de sang sont
retrouvées dans le navire, cette thèse est
reprise par Conan Doyle dans une version romancée
de l'histoire.
Certains soupçonnent même l'équipage du
Dei Gratia d'avoir attaqué le Mary Céleste
ou d'avoir comploté avec son équipage...
Certains évoquent plutôt un phénomène
naturel comme une trombe, qui expliquerait
l'eau dans les cales et les cabines.
Ou bien le navire était passé au dessus
de l'Atlantide, pile dans l'axe entre le triangle
des Bermudes et les pyramides de Gizeh, on
connaît bien ce genre de théories.
Fait amusant: un épisode de Doctor Who
lui est consacré en 1965, dans Flight Through
Eternity.
Une histoire semblable arrive au Carroll A.
Deering, une goélette qui faisait son voyage
de retour de Rio de Janeiro vers la Virginie.
Le 31 janvier 1921, elle est retrouvée échouée
au large de la Caroline du Nord.
L'équipage, les instruments et de nombreux
effets personnels avaient disparu avec les
canots de secours, alors qu'un reste de repas
en cours de préparation fut retrouvé dans
les cuisines.
Ce vaisseau fantôme a lui aussi entraîné
son lot de théorie et de fausses preuves,
d'autant qu'il passait réellement par le
triangle des Bermudes, mais les autorités
penchent pour une mutinerie ou une attaque
de pirates.
Plus récemment encore puisque l'affaire date
de cet été, le Sam Rataulangi, un cargo
indonésien disparu depuis 2009, a été retrouvé
en août échoué sur un banc de sable en
Birmanie sans cargaison ni équipage.
Et il existe énormément d'autres histoires
de ces navires fantômes, mais encore une
fois les autres que j'ai pu trouver n'existaient
que sur des sites absolument fiables tels
que creepypastafromthecrypt ou mysterium incognita...
On est loin de la fiabilité historique, mais
si vous voulez rire je vous invite à faire
quelques recherches sur le Ourang Medan:
il y a même des photos MONTAGES, c'est magnifique.
Face à la recrudescence de tous ces VRAIS
navires fantômes, abandonnés pour différentes
raisons et posant un danger de taille pour
les navires à l'équipage bien vivant qui
risquaient de les croiser sur les mers, le
gouvernement américain prend des mesures
en créant un service spécial chargé de
recenser ces épaves.
Selon lui il y en aurait eu une vingtaine
dérivant quelque part en Atlantique Nord
à la fin du XIXe siècle, et en 1908 l'USCGC
Seneca est mis à flot dans le but de détruire
ces vaisseaux à grands coups de dynamite.
Il en aurait détruit une dizaine jusque 1912,
avant d'être assigné à la surveillance
des icebergs en Atlantique Nord suite au naufrage
du Titanic.
Comme l'année dernière avec les revenants,
mon propos ici n'était pas de vous faire
peur à coup de mythes invérifiés mais de
tenter d'aller au delà de ces histoires d'au
delà qui fascinèrent les pêcheurs du XVIIIe
siècle, les lecteurs du XIXe et les amateurs
de creepypasta du XXIe.
Les vaisseaux fantômes réels sont injustement
nommés puisqu'on n'y trouve pas plus de fantômes
que dans votre placard, enfin, il me semble,
mais ont inspiré tellement de légendes marines
qu'il devient difficile de démêler le vrai
du faux.
On peut tout de même retenir que comme pour
beaucoup de légendes marines trouvant une
explication toute rationnelle dès l'instant
où on fouille sous la surface, les vaisseaux
fantômes ont et continuent d'exister, sans
malédictions, et sans fantômes.